yo what's going on guys Rock Here I am
super pumped - you guys are going to
check out my new movie Jumanji I play a
world Explorer I may have a super
strength or two and plus I'm a guy who
can take down anything with a boomerang
jungle style enjoy Wow this fun group
welcome to detention Spencer
Bethany fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason
you should be thinking about who you are
and who you want to pay you'll have
plenty of time to figure that out while
you're cleaning out the basement are you
going to help
are you too pretty I'm too pretty yo
what's this a game for those who seek to
find a way to leave their world behind
Jumanji
pick a character and you're that person
in the game which one real quick I don't
think it matters how much you scream or
it sounds like a better I'll be the
curvy genius dr. smolder brave stone
guess um Ruby roundhouse
guys Lizzie where's the rest of me
my god Britt Humphries who used me
Spencer who's she
[Music]
what I'm wearing half a shirt and shorts
shorts in the jungle thinks we got
sucked into Jumanji and we become the
avatars we chunk so that means Bethany
only Bethany don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man I don't have
my claritin and all I see around here is
Paul well I don't have a top two feet of
my life
damn as a man right there don't cry
don't cry don't cry it's gonna be okay
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
that was so intense I like can't even
with this step in here
[Music]
any world in a coma what not okay
machine local like you get in there
saver
I'm not gonna get in there you get it
now yeah I got a backpack oh don't get
water with a backpack everybody knows
that
you